من الرياض بمعنى الان مراسلنا سعيد جابر
سعيد اهلا بك بدايه هل من تفاصيل اكثر حول
برنامج هذا اليوم وبرنامج القمتين
العربيه الصينيه وكذلك الخليجيه الصينيه
وهذه القمتين ستشهد العديد من الاجتماعات
الثنائيه بين قاده ال- بعض القاده العرب
وكذلك الرئيس الصيني همم
السعوديه والصين مفتاح الشرق الاوسط او
عملاقه الاقتصاد العالمي هذا ما يمكن ان
يتم تفسيره خلال اللقاء همم القائم في
العاصمه الرياض والذي يتمثل في هذه
الزياره يجب القول اليوم ان العالم جريمه
ينظر الى الرياض وهذا له عده متنبات
الموضع العالمي الجديده الصين تعتبر قطبا
اقتصاديا لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه عالميا
همم جميع الدول العربيه اليوم في القمه
العربيه الصينيه تعتبر ان الصين همم
الجلوس على طاوله واحده معها والتفاهم
وتباحث
يتاهل في تنميه البلدان العربيه كذلك
القمه العربيه الخليجيه وقاده الدول
الخليجيه يبحثون سيبحثون اليوم مع القاده
ااه قاده قائد همم رئيس الصين ايضا ما
يساهم في تنميه الخليج العربي هذه تعتبر
همم يعني تنميه اقتصاديه لوصول الدول
العربيه للعالم الاخر السعوديه في مقابل
الامر تقدم نفسها ايضا على انها بوابه
الشرق الاوسط الضامنه لبلوغ اقتصاد الصين
للجزء الاخر من العالم هناك اشاره في غايه
الاهميه قدمتها الرياض خلال هذه الزياره
وهي همم انه هناك اكثر من 30 رئيسا
وداعيما عربيا يجلسون على طاوله واحده مع
العملاق العالمي يبدو ان السعوديه ايضا
همم توجه رساله ايضا قادره على استقبال
الرئيس الصيني لتقول ايضا همم للقاده
العرب انتم الان على نفس الطاوله
وبامكانكم التفاهم وتباعد في ما يتعلق
بالدول العربيه وتنميتها نعمه
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه التجاره الحره
المتعثره الانجازات تعبير مذو 2010
هل من مؤشرات على احتمال انهاء هذه
الاتفاقيه اليوم
الحره ما بين الدول دول الخليج العربي
والصين همم محور الحديث في القمه
هناك ايضا عقود بالمليارات اعتقد
ينظر لها همم هناك انباء متواتر عن صفقات
السلاح المثنى ابراها خلال القمه الخليجيه
الصينيه وتقدر بقرابه 30 مليار دولار بين
اجانب الصيني والجانب السعودي ايضا لديها
عقود مع الجانب الصيني في مدينه نيوم
الحالي ما يقدر ب 500 مليار دولار ربما
تحتل هذه الصفقه المرتبه الاولى من حيث
حجم العقود وهذا يخفي اهميه الكبرى لهذه
الزياره التي ربما لها صناع القرار بعين
همم
شكرا جزيلا كابرس لنا من الرياض سعيد
الجبر